let's go to the eight six five area code
caller from eight six five go ahead hi
I'm Jason I was wondering if you knew
anything about the new Social Credit
they're implementing and China what'd
you think about that yeah so basically
for people who don't know
China's instituting a new Social Credit
System where based on your it's almost
like a reputation score they're kind of
like gamifying life it's an interesting
thing you might not be allowed for
periods of time to like get on airplanes
and what else is it Jason that you can
be prevented from doing even on like
subways and stuff renting cars getting
loans yeah things that can affect it
apparently also include not just that
but like if you pay your bills on time
like things financial crisis like
they're combining financial credit with
a social aspect yeah listen I think it's
super interesting because it's just
different and new but I think it's
probably a bad idea I think those types
of initiatives will disproportionately
hurt people who are already in less than
ideal circumstances and continue to
widen the wealth and inequality gap and
I think over the long term it will be
not a good thing
yeah I think it could work in China for
a while at least just because of the way
that Chinese people's thought processes
are there here so you know American and
Westerners do you think intimate it
could be implemented possibly in other
countries oh sure I mean you could
implement it in a lot of different
places and a lot of how it works will be
determined by the culture of the place
but I think like if you did something
like that in the United States you will
literally create an additional new
underclass of underprivileged people who
will be literally blocked from some of
the mechanisms which they could use to
better their lives and it would be a
disastrous death spiral yep all right
thank you for the call appreciate it
yeah I haven't had a chance to comment
on that but it is a very very
interesting thing